so many people who miss interpret the
picture that I had I don't know I don't
know what's there to misinterpret yes
yes yes
sister Maria X Oh Oh wherever you want
to call it
you are right sister from a Jew for now
with my clothes had holes in them I'm
after always picky so the night better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are doing well I'm
having an amazing day and if I'm having
an amazing day you should be having an
amazing day
this is why I'm sorry usually says in
his rocks before he starts him what
parfum and slim I'm sure you guys be
watching it together I'm not really
having an amazing day today now I'm
gonna tell you guys why now before we
start it's not gonna be all that you
know judgmental net Haram police and you
know this is so hard on we're not gonna
go there I have no problem with this
individual mmm maybe a little bit
problem with our Bravo because he's our
Bravo yeah you should know better but
we're gonna talk about this because
we're gonna talk about exactly what went
on here we're gonna talk about a lot of
things that I found out today actually
before I was just doing this video I
went to see a few stuff Adam started in
do now and he's got this new podcast
racially profile not really profile
something like that anyways I come from
here so we're gonna go and watch that
but let's just understand what on earth
has been going on
who is this guy or girl whoever he
classifies his gender as which is his
right he can call himself go guy
gender-neutral he can be wherever he
likes yeah in the world that we live in
he can be whatever he likes and we're
gonna talk about what actually happened
so I'm gonna do this I'm gonna go to the
video and we're going to find out so
let's start it from around 7 minutes so
this is where Adam Sarla our brother in
Islam we don't hate him we hate the
action or the things that he does and
we're going to learn some things because
there's some stuff he says that is
profound now I've done many videos
before gustan videos about prophet Adam
trying to advise him back six years ago
six years ago six years ago and we just
want to see where things have been going
from there onwards
you know the meet and greets issues to
the music videos he got into his girls
in his bed all that kind of stuff well
he's the same person who said that he
would not like it if we was to ask for
his sister's name or his wife's name
it's very disrespectful but the same
person is in bed with different girls
but if that was I'm even gonna do an
example of his sister cuz he will find
is very offensive and he might be very
enraged and angry rightly so but when
these other people's sisters it's
alright we call this hypocrisy and same
with Brava slim.i but nothing personal
against you guys I'm just trying to be
real out here here our own relationship
destroys people destroys them and you
are dating a yo and you promote it
openly if I was to say Bravo slim can I
date your sister you wouldn't like it I
know while you're watching this you're
gonna be thinking nah man you know I'm a
I'm a challenging to a boxing match or
something like that yeah you know we
can't maybe do that but it's hard to hit
the face of a Muslim and to fight
another believer yeah that's a different
story we don't want to go there so I
don't want no a box and challenges
however if you're too eager um if you
come to London you can let me know if
you want it's not free I'm just saying
if you're really really eager you know
you can come and we can mean to talk as
brothers
but if you want to get physical then
that's up to you and would you see what
happens after about anyways I'm not
gonna go there I'm not gonna be childish
here I'm listening around okay I'm
joking there's nothing that's gonna I'm
talking guys here he's our brother in
religion but I'm just trying to point
out the hypocrisy here would you like if
I was to date your sister you don't like
it then why do you do in promoting
hypocrisy of men a lot of men do this
because Apocrypha and then you want
virgin I want to marry a virgin yeah you
got sleep around I'm not seeing you guys
off I wouldn't mean I'm not accusing you
guys anyways anyways I'm going on a
tangent let's Korean let's watch the
video let's watch the video here we go
super dope yeah and we're gonna go watch
the super dope or I'm talking about
smoking dope oh just a quick
don't judge me if there's anyone out
there saying you know oppa Ali's drunk
judge I'm so sorry this is not to pack
yeah
only god can judge me don't
this is not to talk we judge from was
apparent yeah if you see me kissing the
girl in public I'm not gonna be my
judging me for broth like why in Trojan
man so don't judge me
we're just trying to advise our prophets
yeah and it's become so pathetic and so
extreme which we saw that we have to be
direct and my message is mainly to his
followers then brother Adam and slim
because we've done many videos well I am
being honest majority I was when I do
these videos is just to make you guys
realize open your eyes what's going on
and not only me other people have
realized this let's carry on look what
he says what does that mean Adam what do
you mean by that I am when aphelion okay
you did the same thing when we first
tried to give you advice that apparently
we called you that gel and you start
crying on camera but what is this like
you know like behavior of you know I'm
thank you for making sure and well
making sure you well what happened why
did you get hit by a car what happened
did you get what did you what happen
brother did you get in an accident you
know this what happened you get into a
fight what do you mean I'm okay you're a
grown man are you trying to eat people
if you're okay why because you took a
picture with somebody who to his
lifestyle it's okay but as a Muslim
you're taking a picture with somebody
who were gonna find out what stuff he
does and you're holding him close to
yourself when I think if I'm not
mistaken he himself is maybe a
homosexual or something I don't know I
don't know and now you're just like okay
thank you for checking up on me that I'm
okay you know after I posted something
Haram when which I got you know backlash
for like I don't understand why this
this excuse and we don't buy that
anymore you know our prophet Adam Harmon
we should we regret what we didn't know
we don't let's carry on watching I mean
I mean I don't know I don't know what's
there to misinterpret like now you it's
not you blaming people
why are you misinterpreting
misinterpreting what what did we say did
the people come and say or why are you
going and you know are you gay or
somewhere not saying that but let's
understand what you're saying you know
on your post which I'm gonna open but
let's just let's just carry on watching
[Music]
was effed up what is it what is that
that it's wrongfully as a Muslim to do
that to promote that to young followers
where they're being polluted with this
gender-neutral you know
are you a girl garner you can be a boy
you feel I know you can be a girl you
know
this is being pumped into our children's
in primary schools it's been trying to
be implemented yeah
I'm not sending hate to anybody if you
reach a certain age and you want to
identify yourself as a woman as a piano
as a robot as a TV television do
whatever you want but what we're trying
to say is that there's that bandwidth
out there you just put it out there okay
why yes yes yes yes sister Maria Oh
wherever you wanna call it
you are right sister you are right if
you watching sister you are right yeah
maybe I don't put that there so you can
get hate but let me tell you something
I am Telling You you are absolutely
right and the Quran and the Sunna
absolutely supports you yeah we see
Muslim YouTube is taking their Muslim
followers to an absolute right we've
seen that over over again with different
all of them once the subscribers in
Greece the Islamic videos be crease and
then it becomes don't judge me you are
absolutely right yes we have noticed
most Muslims who have some sort of fame
in the YouTube seen acting kind of funny
yes to lose themselves and it's none
with it yes we see that we see that so
please and this is what he said by the
way the bomb finally
met my crush she's a sweetheart haha so
funny so funny and what I look in the
background is putting some emotional
music now what you want us to do cry I
didn't cry oh my gosh how could people
do that to Adam get a grip man grow up
you're a big man grow up yeah you have
to grow up you're going and polluting
your young youngsters minds and you want
us to have pity on you I'm not having no
pity on you brother so sorry
no pity on you nope it's your new
brother okay interesting
whoa now anyone that advises him or is
against him Isis now can you imagine if
the prophet sawa body was Selim and the
companions Oh madam a cut-up well you
wouldn't want to be around Oh Myron cut
up you know I'm telling you and Abu
Bakar adelio rather and ali radiya Lohan
if they were here and they were telling
you brother Adam may Allah bless you but
I think this is you know a wrong what
are you gonna say o Messenger of Allah
stop acting like Isis is that what
you're gonna say I said now you've given
us anywhere Isis will become Isis
members and this is exactly what the
fire Isis we are Isis members why
because we're telling you what you're
doing is wrong it is wrong WR Ong it's
wrong oh no no they know Isis there what
about if you told them you know what
what I'm doing is chemically is wrong
then Isis what I'm doing is wrong why
don't you say that and you'll hear like
trying to make you want to cook you for
it like oh you know don't thank you for
defending us not really you're making
your own self look stupid you're making
us look stupid you're doing things that
you know there's sometimes people must
have used to and stuff and you have
non-muslims come and say you know in
your religion you know I'm supposed to
do that
you know when you're like oh in a
relationship you know
store-bought manipulation with some
comments it isn't that haram do you know
how embarrassing that is knowing that a
disbeliever and telling you what you're
doing is embarrassing so look at this
now he's begin up the people has
defended in bigger bigger draaga bigger
exactly these are just a pick a random
point and turn it against him when they
don't know the full story bigger bit
yeah
defend and this one think I've seen
about you before Adam Mohammadi job you
mentioned him by name yeah Rafa his mom
and he's our prophet your brother your
brother him how many jobs are brothers
well I work with him he's a close friend
of mine you mentioned him
you mentioned him the only reason you
mention them is because the issue that
we had with sister Dina and her husband
and he big drop and said you're a boxer
and her husband Syd should be a bit
careful you love being priest but when
it comes to advice you don't want to
know when it comes to someone correct
you don't want to know when someone
beats you up you're a box or something
like that all of a sudden you mention
how many jobs name you're in contact
with him and I spoke to his job I said
brother he tried to speak to him you
have connection speak to him he's even
disappointed in what you do it's ugly
yeah he's disappointed so what is he a
bad guy now is he now he's a badly you
don't want to know him anymore let's be
real here please anyway let's move on
from this
ya know let's go to this other profile
thing that he's doing here so I want you
guys to understand what lie I'm sorry
our youngsters are being misled on a
continuous basis and taken for a right
from by these brothers sadly yeah I'm
not here to say I'm better than you I'm
not better than you I don't know where
I'm gonna be I don't know where you're
gonna be
you could repent to be better than me
but that doesn't negate the fact that I
have to as your brother
as you or at least advise your followers
to open their eyes these people don't
care about you they do not care about
you so let's watch this so here this is
this very interesting the app is about
Adam started catching uber everywhere
and let's see what the reason is
which you shouldn't even expose your
sins yeah I would say you shouldn't
really even expose uses now people go oh
but now you're exposing his sin well
it's public now when I heard he was
joking so he's basically saying this is
a reason why caches love you burs he
smokes weed and that's the reason why
yeah so I'm from the Matis guy you know
this guy's joking taken off by Allah
like sad
listen to what he's he takes smokes weed
him looks like he's uncomfortable with
it and he looks like about his reaction
he seems like sin looks like he's maybe
I don't know I'm just assuming I'm not
saying here's maybe he's tried because
he said something after but I don't
think he's okay with it cause look how
he's acting look he's not condoning
pickup slim so I'm sorry big up to you
because now you enjoin and would have
forbidden evil so you're saying look he
said that I'm not telling anybody to do
it that is laughs that's correct in your
brother free charge or no judges on
Bubba don't expose your sins you know
you don't need to tell everyone
everything I'm a sinner don't you said I
commit sins Allah protects me Allah and
Allah doesn't protects me I don't need
to tell people and we know one of the
process Adam said that the ones only
ones that won't be forgiven are those
who go and tell this since to everybody
look free judge don't look you're making
the guy uncomfortable now is that okay
if readers don't okay yeah Adam you can
say that no okay
people violate anybody like what you
just did but he looks like is his cross
and he didn't even know this look in the
beginning oh my god it's like everywhere
you know what I think of marijuana
personally what I think I just think you
know if you know how to limit yourself
and do your thing like it won't be it
can't be that bad but like there's
people out there like especially money
but I feel I grew up with you know
they're they smoke so much weed like not
almost well they do bro like literally
like can't be kind of be honest with you
everyone was listening to I'm like I
don't I don't like I don't know too much
or nothing like that like that what does
that mean take I can control myself
every addict starts were small and you
become an addict nice it's a dangerous
substance and now you even just defined
that it's just getting worse and worse
and wasn't it just a fine thing that
it's okay I do it sometimes to get to
get some work done this is fundamental I
get I do it just to get some work done
and more of most of the artists when
they're doing these things they're
taking drugs why why because you need it
to go you're going from stuff and that's
the only thing that's gonna keep it
going
drugs alcohol etc this is peak man this
is peak I'm not gonna keep this long oh
no I'm just gonna say it small that it's
sad you'll take your picture with
someone what like I had to get some
people from our team to look this guy
that you took a picture with yet like I
said they sent me some pictures which
I'll show you guys cause he's um he's a
man like he's no it's not he is a man
yeah okay
biologically he is a man and they showed
me I said why show me this girl's
picture humble or it was a woman because
he's a man I was like nah cause there's
no it's a it's a man and he looks just
like a woman now that person can be
whatever they like don't get treated I'm
not giving me but it can be whatever
they like that's their lifestyle man as
a Muslim Muslim you know brother
had them just understand these things
I'm not gonna bring your happiness I
don't know why you're doing what you're
doing but he just seems are you
gradually getting worse Bravo please
Matt if you don't care about yourself
care about your followers don't put
stuff out there need to be out there and
one laggy which is like like I said
before this movie video is mainly done
for you guys if Father Adam takes a you
know in this year for me he can if he
doesn't want to no problem but for you
guys understand don't be taken for a
ride on the day of judgement none of us
we're gonna flee for our life Rob Adams
also gonna give a damn about you don't
go for it and just MBLAQ oh we we did
okay I'm sorry to say this is okay Adam
sorry that's it
this guy these people are your role
models when in Romans in Romans the
prophets of Lagos Elam is your role
model and we asked a lot of parents have
guide them in us
what else can I see it's sad wallahi
it's sad and people think I like doing
this stuff to do you know how to just
get some time to just do this anyways
brothers and sisters take care look
after ya look after yourselves in sha
Allah all praises belong to Allah
sponsors I'll ask a lot to keep me
guided and keep them guided all of us
I'm not better than him he's not better
than me Allah knows only well lie I'm
not looking down on them but we judge
from us apparent because I'm a diamond
cut up said wish to judge for revelation
now revelation a stop we judge from what
apparent as simple as that
and the hate that you got I'm so sorry
in the context of correction you deserve
it and if you want to call it Isis
because of that call us whatever you
like cuz we will not stop we will not
stop advising our brothers in a good way
in a good way without insulting
shouting screaming going Hellfire we
will advise
til next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullah better care to